Goria ! A deux ans la petite gloria est
en pleine forme elle ne quitte pas d'une
semelle sa maman Bolinas hormis pour
son entraînement médical hebdomadaire
target ...OK
au moment où gloria va
toucher la cible moi je vais siffler et du coup
c'est là qu'elle qu'après elle a sa récompense
son péché mignon des morceaux de pomme. malgré les
barreaux de protection le soigneur doit garder un
lien pour rassurer l'animal
target
ok
donc là on voit qu'elle
est complètement sur la balance donc si je me
retourne je vois qu'elle fait actuellement 455,6
ça veut dire qu'elle a pris 10
kilos depuis son dernier training
à l'âge adulte gloria pourrait
atteindre deux tonnes, le poids
normal pour une femelle hippopotame
les mâles comme son papa Quido
grossistes tout au long de leur vie
avec leurs canines pouvant atteindre
60 cm il arrive qu'il y ait de petits bobos
on est sur des blessures très légères c'est
juste qu'on va avoir des marques sur la peau
ça c'est le principal c'est des griffures
et sinon après on peut avoir des problèmes de
dents dans la mâchoire en général mieux que
quand ils jouent entre eux ils ouvrent
fort la gueule et peuvent se blesser
aussi à l'intérieur de la mâchoire
et quand il joue avec sa fille Quido
n'hésite pas à montrer les dents.
l'eau reste le lieu privilégié de
l'hippopotame qui vit 80% de son temps
En fait l'hippopotame il est pas capable de
suer comme nous on transpire du coup il a la
peau qui sèche très vite et il va sécréter une
substance qu'on appelle de la sueur de sang
qui est en fait une substance rouge qui va
lui permettre de protéger sa peau des rayons
du soleil il va pas être capable de rester
trop longtemps au soleil parce que sa peau
va se craqueler et va blanchir du coup il
a toujours besoin d'être un peu en contact
avec de l'eau pour être le mieux possible
comme tout mammifères l'hippopotame ne peux
pas respirer sous l'eau mais il peut rester
en apnée jusqu'à 30 minutes de quoi faire
pâlir les meilleurs plongeurs de la planète